[Music]
michael
is with us michael's in dayton ohio hi
michael how are you
hey dave good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
yeah so in june my wife and i uh
switched to a
different internet provider and after we
did that
we were expecting it they sent us a bill
for the unreturned equipment
so we sent it back and we received
confirmation that the
provider received it and then in august
we received
another bill for 59 for a supposed third
piece of equipment that we never
received when we first
began the contract with them and they've
continued to call us asking for payment
for this
equipment and then after three attempts
of trying to resolve this
trying to explain that we never received
anything if we had it we'd give it back
to you you've already received two
pieces of equipment
and so now they're saying they're
sending it to collections and so while i
want to stand my ground and
uh not pay for something that we never
received should i
attempt to fight this or should i just
pay the fee of 59
it's up to you i mean you
but here's the thing you're gonna have
to get above the idiots you've been
talking to
right and they are idiots because if you
talk to someone and you explain
something like that and they can't help
you get resolution on it
instead they just open a collections
file i mean this is somebody whose
parents are cousins you're going to have
to get above them
all right and so you know i'm going to
have 59
worth of but you and just for the fun of
it somewhere
in this organization right uh at some
point you may pay it at some point you
may get mad enough you hire an attorney
and sue them but
um but that's the problem you know the
number one consumer complaint
with cable companies is the incompetent
employees
and there's like comcast stories there's
verizon stories
that are all i mean they're like a
youtube phenomenon rachel you know what
i'm talking about oh yeah well they
and they and they cycle through them i
mean these people don't stay at these
jobs well especially the debt collectors
that's a whole other
industry but it's almost the same thing
they're just in these cubicles and they
just and they quit 90 days later i mean
like the
the amount of rotation that they go
through chances of talking to the
same person so that's it you got to keep
going and going and going and it's a
pain
so honestly i love the conviction dan
but you may get a few months down the
road and just
pay the 59 because you're just tired of
it which sounds like you're surrendering
and i hate that the justice part of me
is like no
yeah don't pay it but there gets to a
point of your quality of life that
you're like you know what it's just
oh it's not worth it but i have to pick
out a few of those to do every year to
get it out of my system and the rest of
them i let them go
because i have a real pile of them i'm a
hillbilly and i will fight you just
because it's fun
and so i have to i have to check myself
on that because i end up with this big
pile of fights
that i picked uh well i didn't pick them
i'm gonna finish them they started it
you didn't start this
so uh but it's just it you know at some
point
you get too much of this crap in your
life by these incompetent people
so which cable company is this uh this
is
our local it's uh called spectrum okay
all right
and that's uh yeah you're in dayton ohio
okay so yeah everybody everybody
everybody in dayton
knows that because we just told them
this cost them a lot more than fifty
nine dollars just now
yeah so spectrum
spectrum hire some competent freaking
people solve this guy's
problem and i tell you what mike i'm
gonna put you on hold
and uh kelly's gonna make sure we have
your contact information if anybody in
spectrum has a backbone or a desire to
actually do
real customer service contact us we'll
put you in touch with mike and we'll
give you credit for cleaning up this
mess
if you want to do it so what are the
odds they do it
no no they won't they won't do it you're
very cynical is your old man
kelly's in the booth going zero okay but
we're getting a chance
we trashed him on the air we'll give him
a chance to fix it i'll go back and say
you guys are wonderful people you fix
michael's problem i'll i will recant
if you fix it if you don't fix it
michael that could have been the justice
you needed just that call just to
put the truth out there as people know i
used to do that more on this show i used
to tear stuff up like that but
um then i figured it out then i figured
out well i figured out i was getting
used
to people calling in i was they were
using me like a weapon and so i had to
quit doing it but occasionally i can
still about once every decade now i
still sneak in and do one
to spectrum in dayton ohio there you go
i feel better already it's just
cleansing it is sad that
they tell us that now 76 of credit
bureaus have errors
on them and 34 of the credit bureau
reports have errors on them that are so
egregious that it would keep you from
getting a loan or keep you from getting
an apartment or whatever
in other words they it's a complete it's
wrong it's not accurate
right it's one thing if you don't pay
your freaking bill but it's just
like this piece of equipment doesn't
even exist ends up on this guy's credit
bureau report
it's a complete lie yep and it wasn't
anybody done with malice it was done by
stupid people it didn't care enough to
fix their problem
when it screws up everyone's life
involved of it right like oh
it's half the credit bureaus yep reports
are
are screwed you know by stuff like that
and by just it's on the wrong account we
the person entering the digits didn't
have enough digits
to enter digits and they just oh god
oh you know crooks make me mad
incompetence almost makes me madder